yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing LNG from Australia right yes use
it under somewhat different yeah it also
has the Union Jack ended up saying are
not completely wrong but it's a bit
different so we have a cruise gambit you
know it will be six yeah before is a
dangerous move here for black even
though I have to say that I don't know
it well okay this should be a fairly
comfortable Hedgehog type situation I
wonder about the mean water while h5
what is the deal with that I didn't that
doesn't look very pressing this move
okay maybe this morning 96 is a
substantial threat if I've was also
interesting but then 94 I mean that
would actually make some sense out of
age five if he goes d6 now I go Bishop
f4 that doesn't look good and then e 5
55 is a very weird specially called type
of position with many n because all sig
move let's say and then if he allows me
to check on these six I'm just grabbing
the bishop pair into dark square so
t6 t6 seems relatively best so he allows
me to check maybe he wants to move a
king vania and go for a counter play
against f2 it might as well be but UK
i'm going to do this first feels like
has to be done anyway yeah and now i
mean i don't have to take immediately on
see a door anything i can wait for him
94 i can now capture quite comfortably
yeah yeah i was i wanted to develop here
possible Bishop f4 we should have fun
looks decent and that only six is
difficult for him to move the c8 bishop
to a six theoretically speaking what
that looks wrong I mean wrong it didn't
look like it needs a less much okay so
why can I not take the pawn okay so i
take it
new cook age for something like that I
think don't see an issue it looks a
little bit shaky I don't see any way to
exploit it look H 423 I mean that also
threatens Bishop g5 i also have long
castles from covering the noise of ok so
now look h4 is definitely an idea i am
an interesting maybe this one securing
f2 preventing look H form
this is not as terrible as it looks at
first really likes pieces are reasonably
active I mean I'm porn up and and should
be better but it's not it looked like a
complete disaster at the beginning and
this isn't all that here yeah so here
Wow if I take it I'm in trouble because
there's chick made and the niners
hanging a half Wow probably have to go
back man it's amazing
now can take before I think just grab on
this one is there anything particularly
wrong with this idea it takes no one
goes to King yeah so here night beehive
or night f5 check sure Frankie move I
don't know if it really does much and to
be honest it looks you cannot take
because of 95 and it's more show off
more than anything
that's also not so clear yeah come on I
have to play some quick a museum that is
to bring it back to III hand what do I
have something else there something
funny King at age 95 takes Queen chicks
textbook and the night but it's got 96
so that should defend that if I could be
nice and nice to play it just didn't
work he takes before now I was thinking
to take and play we should be six this
isn't all that fantastic ready you both
down to one minute after seven tables
and now basically playable the chest
time morning yeah I want to get some
attack going here maybe you can take III
TI take five Queen g5 but the [ __ ]
should do should help I'm not blundering
into made down something hey I would be
most embarrassing
hook the more next em from black for it
on high who's made it a really good
defensive job there in this in this
position which was really a pretty much
unplayable after move seven also like he
added that should be winning for while
almost and took too bad that DB sorry we
should cease fire Bishop f4 is given by
the comp yeah that is maybe better and
this is what so clearly I mean it must
be better for white but it wasn't
winning or anything as we see Anakin's
future on the engine the edge is 0.6 Ned
wasn't involved all that clear really
not yeah you're taking was simplest I
intended to take and play Bishop be six
maybe only one I wasn't quite sure about
that one because this is also neglecting
queen age for stuff king GH seems to be
good for black I mean the Lucas tulane
are you Queen a fourth good haha ok now
again this is a show of move a little
bit justices as I wanted to bring it to
e3 this is not working unfortunately
because I even this is ok so I was just
seeing this which defends as well now I
defended this really okay I mean that's
it for now Candice is better for me
again you have the big event at that
time we were flying basically a bullet
came in
when he had spent so much time to get to
the position after 17 18 moves ok guys
thanks for watching